[MUSIC PLAYING]
MEGAN O'KEEFE: My
name is Megan O'Keefe.
SANDEEP PARIKH:
I'm Sandeep Parikh.
MEGAN O'KEEFE: And we are
here to talk to you all
about how we deal
with problems in Istio
when things inevitably go wrong.
We're super excited
today to mostly do
demos in this session.
The first thing I'm
going to do, just
to cue up Sandeep's demos,
is give a bit of background
about why Istio
can be difficult,
and what we're really
here today to talk about.
This slide may be
familiar to a lot of you.
When you move from a sort
of monolithic application
into microservices, a lot
of challenges can arise.
When you start
decoupling your code
into maybe different
languages and frameworks,
and different
services, it can be
tough to keep track
of everything.
Things like service discovery.
All of a sudden you
have lots of network
calls that you may
not have had before.
This can cause congestion
in the network reliability.
So inevitably, with the
complexity of microservices,
there's more things
to keep track of
and things inevitably go down.
Security-- you now have
more points of entry
into the application.
Instead of one firewall
rule, you might have many.
And finally, aggregating
metrics and logs.
So you need kind
of a way to bring
all of the information about
your services together.
Ideally into something like
a single pane of glass.
And while Kubernetes addresses
some of the scaling and life
cycling challenges
of microservices,
and is an incredibly
powerful piece of technology,
it doesn't solve
all those problems.
So the goal of Istio is to help
unify microservices and the way
that you manage them through
an additional set of platform.
To give a review of
what Istio provides,
and some of the things
we'll be diving into today,
it's a somewhat
complex architecture
in which there are
multiple control plane
components managing a
set of envoy proxies.
So at the bottom there,
we have the control plane.
Consists of Pilot,
Mixer, Galley, Citadel,
which handle traffic
management, telemetry policy,
config ingestion, and
certain keys respectively.
We will go into some
of the specifics today.
And then up there at the top,
we have the envoy proxies.
These comprise the data plane.
These are the things
that we are configuring
via the Istio control plane.
And what does Istio get you?
It helps address some of
this complexity challenge.
Unified traffic management,
centralized policy checks,
telemetry ingestion,
custom adapters
for the logs and metric
system of your choice,
and automated service identity,
so that with Istio you
can turn on mutual TLS end
to end service encryption
with a single policy.
But--
Raise your hand
if you have tried
to bring Istio into production
at your organization.
Keep your hand up if it
has been a challenge.
Istio is still a somewhat
new piece of technology.
It's gone through some
changes, released 1.1
a couple of weeks ago.
And there are some challenges
when adopting Istio, especially
on top of Kubernetes.
And the first is that, with
those multiple control plane
components that I showed in
that diagram, there's just a lot
going on.
All of the pieces
kind of fit together
and generate a lot of logs.
The APIs that Istio exposes
are broad and complex
and highly configurable.
There are many, many ways to
configure a virtual service
in Istio, and this can get
challenging when something goes
wrong because you're
like, is this even
a valid virtual
service, for instance.
There's a lot of paths
to a failing state,
and we're here today to
demo some of those paths.
The other thing
we want to stress
is that, as developer
relations for Google,
we really want to know
how folks are using Istio,
and where are the gaps in the
tooling and in the ecosystem
so that we can help try to
address that at Google and out
in the broader community.
So we did want to mention that.
You'll see us using things
like curl throughout this demo,
and if you've used
Istio, you may also just
be kind of stuck in this loop
of just repeatedly curling
[? when ?] things go wrong, and
we acknowledge that as well.
So without further
ado, we're going
to go into three
hands-on demos today.
My colleague here
is going to handle
the first couple addressing
traffic management
and telemetry, and I
will be picking up again
in a little while to
cover authentication.
Take it away.
SANDEEP PARIKH: Thanks, Megan.
So we're going to just start
around traffic management.
So how do you debug
Istio traffic routing?
So as a quick
recap, the way Pilot
works, you take your virtual
service rules, your gateway
rules, your policies, you push
them up to the control plane.
Pilot make sure those
rules get pushed out
to all the envoy proxies.
And there are
mechanisms built in
to figure out, are my envoy
proxies in sync with the pilot
rules that were
sent to the cluster,
and what are those differences.
And we can see and
examine the configuration
on both sides of that.
So the traffic API, and this
is just a small subset of it.
We couldn't really go
through all of it here.
But just as again a
quick recap, there
is this idea of sort of
north-south, inbound and
outbound traffic into and
out of your service mesh.
And then there's
east-west traffic,
which is in and out traffic
within the service mesh itself.
So north and south are Gateway
and Service Entry respectively.
And then within a cluster,
or within a service mesh
I should say, the east-west
is Virtual Service
and Destination Rule.
So those are the objects that
we use to configure things
like traffic splitting, traffic
steering, or ingress or egress.
How many of you have used
Bookinfo from the Istio samples
repo there?
That's almost everybody.
Perfect.
Well we wanted to create
another little version of it,
so I made something
called Weather Info
that we're going to use here.
It's a simple front
end with two back ends.
Nothing terribly
complicated, but it
lets us comb through the logs a
little bit easier because it's
a smaller application.
So this is what
the UI looks like.
It just shows you the weather.
With V1, it shows you the
weather in a single city,
and in V2 it shows you the
weather in multiple cities.
That's all this thing does.
It's got an outbound API call
to a weather API [? servant, ?]
so we've got that [? servant ?]
entry as well for that.
So the problem that we're having
with this deployment, though,
is that we pushed this code up,
we pushed our virtual service
rules, everything is out
there in the service mesh,
but what we're seeing is
50/50 splits of traffic.
Not the 90/10 we've specified.
And for those of you that
are familiar with doing this
in Kubernetes, when you
deploy things by default,
you get this kind of
50/50 round robin routing.
You're not getting any
kind of particular split
unless you've got different
ratios of pods out there.
In our case, we've got each.
One of V2 and one of V1, but
we're still seeing 50/50.
We're not seeing again
that 90/10 split.
So the way this was
deployed, and I just
want to do this
instead of showing
you guys more yaml
at the moment,
but the way it's deployed is--
configured ingress gateway
with a gateway policy
and a virtual service to direct
inbound traffic to the weather
frontend.
Weather frontend then
has a destination rule
and a virtual service that
splits the traffic 90/10.
And then we've got one service
century for that weather API
call.
So with that, can we
switch to this laptop demo?
Can you guys read that OK?
All right, so let's just
take a quick look at what's
deployed in this cluster.
So this is a GKE cluster
with the Istio add on.
It sets a permissive
mode deployed out there,
and I can show you the pods
that are in there as well.
So that's the first place
we're going to look.
We're going to look at the
pods we've got running.
Weather frontend
is working fine,
and so are the two weather
backend versions as well.
Let's check the services and
make sure those are actually
set up correctly as well.
So we could see the weather
backend service is also
configured correctly.
And then we can actually
dig into the objects
that we pushed up earlier.
So I can say kubectl
get virtualservice,
and there's a virtual
service for weather backend.
And that's the one
that directs traffic
from the frontend
to that 90/10 split.
So we can actually
look at that in depth.
And so this dumps out a
little bit extra output.
But here we can see
that the host that we're
trying to identify
here, weather backend,
and we've got a destination
in route here with 90% and 10%
down here.
So again, this
should be working.
But if we take a
look at the UI--
and I'll just hit refresh
a couple times here.
I pulled this up a
little bit earlier.
It's roughly showing
us about a 50/50 split.
Again, we should be
seeing a lot more
of the single
version, which is just
a single city in this case.
So let me flip back.
And the next thing
I'm going to do--
again, we need some sort
of troubleshooting mode,
have a lot of steps
to choose from,
and we're trying to do it in
sort of an orderly fashion.
But Megan and I were
talking about this earlier.
It's sort of a cyclical process.
You end up kind of going
back through again and again.
But the steps I'd sort
of like the take here
are, the first things are
one, just checking the basics.
Did my pods and services
get up there correctly,
are all the Istio policies
I pushed running correctly,
like virtual service
destination rule, et cetera.
So those are all in there and
those are those look fine,
so we've got to dig
a little deeper.
So the first thing
I'm going to do here
is make sure that within
the cluster itself
we're not seeing the routing.
Maybe the problem is
weather frontend maybe
if I try another service
that's inside the cluster
and inside the service mesh we
might see different behavior.
So if you remember, there was
a pod there earlier called
recipe.
That's a little utility
that Meghan wrote just
to compare response types.
So I'm quickly going
to execute a command
inside that container.
Never type live.
All right, so what
this is going to do,
it's going to issue 1,000 quick
requests to the weather backend
service on a little endpoint
that we created a call version,
just to compare response types.
And again, even within the
service mesh inside the cluster
itself, we're
still seeing 50/50.
So the problem is somewhere
else in the stack.
So one of the things
I'd like to do next
is check the envoy proxy
from the outbound side.
So in this case, we
can look at the weather
frontend on a proxy log and see
if anything shows up in there.
The first thing I'll do
is grab the frontend pod.
All right, so we're going
to use that frontend
a whole bunch later on here.
So first thing I'm going
to do is get the logs
from the envoy
proxy from that pod.
MEGAN O'KEEFE: The metadata.
SANDEEP PARIKH: Oh, thanks.
See, this is why you
should never do it live.
So that's a lot of log
detail, but we can actually
start to dig in here
and see what's going on.
And we see a whole
bunch of inbound calls.
We're actually
looking for outbounds,
so I'm going to quickly
grep here for outbound.
It's a little bit
easier to read.
So we can see outbound
calls from weather frontend
to weather backend.
And something that
you'll start to get
used to looking at and
understanding when you look
at the envoy logs is
this whole line here,
it's saying try to make an
outbound call on port 5,000
to weather backend.
But you'll notice there's
a little extra gap there
between those two pipes.
Well, what that's telling us is
it's not directing the traffic
to a particular version.
It's just sending the traffic
out to weather backend.
And again, we're falling back to
Kubernetes round robin routing.
It's not using the Istio service
mesh routing that we set up.
So now it starts a little
bit more interesting.
This is where you're
going to start digging
into the Istio control proxy
configuration commands.
So Istio Control is
a binary that we ship
with the Istio release itself.
And so that actually has a ton
of useful debugging commands.
And I'm going to scroll
up a little bit here.
But it's a great, powerful
tool to really dig
into how the proxy is configured
and how things are set up.
So here we're actually
going to use things
like proxy status
and proxy config
to dig into where the problem
is, and try to understand
it a little bit better.
So the first thing I'm going to
do is check their proxy status.
And so we can see that, for all
of our proxies-- and the ones
we care about are in the
default namespace of weather
backend multiple,
single, and frontend--
and those are all synced.
All those rules are
current and synced
and they're getting them from
this particular pilot pod.
We can check the weather
frontend one specifically.
You always have to specify the
pod name and the namespace.
And so here what we'll see--
again, the cluster
configurations match,
the listeners match,
and the routes match.
So what that's telling
us is that, again,
the envoy proxy knows
everything that Pilot knows.
So the rules we
push the Pilot, they
have made their way over to
the onboard proxy running
in weather frontend.
But we still haven't figured
out what the problem is.
So how do we again
continue to dig further?
And that's where the proxy
config command comes in.
So proxy config on frontend
will show us a little bit more
detail.
There's a couple of
sub-commands here.
So you want to check the
first cluster configuration
on the frontend pod.
And what this will
tell us is all
of the sort of
outbound components
that it can send things
to are inbound services
that it can send information to.
So again, we see here we've got
weather backend with no version
information, and it knows
that it can send things
to multiple and single.
But the question is,
why is it not happening?
So it looks like, again,
the configurations
have made their way across.
Well let's check one
more component, which
is the outbound routes
from that envoy proxy,
because that could
be another issue.
So again, Istio Control, proxy
config on the frontend pod,
and we're going to
look at the routes.
So these routes are
just based on port name.
And so we see that there are
a bunch of series of routes
just for individual
different services running
inside the service mesh.
In particular, our
weather backend
is running on port 5,000.
So let's take a look at
that one in depth here.
All right, so we could
see that one specifically,
and it's only got
one virtual host.
So that right there
tells us there
might be a problem, because we
actually have two hosts there.
We've got weather
backend running
in the V1 and the
V2 configuration,
so we should have more than
one virtual host outbound.
So let's take a
look at that one.
And actually you can
output that as json.
Now I'm going to do
this the first time just
so you can see the output,
because it's lengthy.
This is a lot to go through.
It's lots to scroll up
and try to read through.
So often what I will do in
these scenarios is actually
filter this using a tool called
jq, which just helps you pass
through json, and I'm actually
going to filter it down
to a particular set of
things I need to look at.
Hopefully that works.
All right.
So it's showing us all
of the outbound services
it knows about on port 5,000,
and here's the problem.
There is actually no route
for this on envoy proxy
to send traffic to
weather backend.
It only knows about sending
traffic back to itself
because the front end service
is also running on port 5,000.
Well, so what's the problem?
How do we figure out from here?
Again, we know the rules have
made it all the way across,
but there's actually no entry in
the route table for that proxy
to send traffic to
weather backend.
Well, as it turns out,
there are two things
you need to do to make
sure your services become
part of the service mesh.
The first one is obviously
adding the sidecar proxy.
So you deploy your pod, you
get that sidecar injected
automatically in your pod, and
that makes it part of the mesh.
But there's actually another
sort of esoteric requirement
that you have to worry
about as well, which
is in your service definition.
So remember I've
got weather backend.
It's got two versions.
So in my deployment I had
two deployments-- weather
backend single, weather
backend multiple--
and I have one Kubernetes
service fronting them.
In that service
definition, you have
to use a very specific naming
convention for your port.
If you just use backend,
it doesn't work.
If you come up with a
name it doesn't work.
You actually have to
specify two parts--
the protocol type,
so in our case http--
and then any kind of
optional identifier.
And so we can actually
take a look at the service
real quickly.
And we can see that that
is the problem itself.
So here in my service
definition, that's the issue.
If that requirement
is not met, that pod
doesn't get picked
up inside the mesh.
I'm going to copy and paste this
really quickly from my notes.
So let's go ahead and
apply that updated service.
And so you can see here what
I did was, all I'm changing
is that one little
port at the bottom.
I changed the name
to http-backend.
So I'm going to go
ahead and commit that.
And in a couple of
seconds, you could actually
tail through some
of the envoy logs
and see new things start
to pop up and happen.
But we can actually just go
right back to Istio Control
and check that same
command earlier,
where we checked all
the outbound routes
and we filtered them
down by name and domain.
And now we see that
weather backend
is a specific available
outbound route.
And if we actually look
at that jq output fully--
again, I apologize
I'm going to have
to scroll a little bit here just
to show you all this really,
really compelling stuff--
there's actually two entries
in this configuration.
There's an entry for multiple,
which is one of the versions,
and there's an entry for single.
That means now it knows that on
port 5,000, there's two routes.
There's one for frontend.
There's one for backend.
And inside that 5,000
route for backend,
there are actually multiple
entries and multiple subsets
it can direct traffic to.
Now I'm going to go and
rerun my recipe command just
to see if we get a
difference in version output
here after 1,000 requests.
It's pretty close.
Well, it looks like there was
one little error along the way
there, but we've
got about a 90/10
split between our services.
So that right there, we're able
to, again, figure this out.
Now what I would say is the
solution to this problem,
turns out, is
relatively trivial.
And if you dig through
the documentation,
this requirement is
really well laid out.
Or at least it's
reasonably well laid out,
in that you have to use the
correct naming convention.
But the purpose of
this demo is really
to show the Istio Control
binary, that mechanism,
is a great debugging tool.
You still need to have some
other things in your toolbox,
like curl, or even jq or grep
to filter through the output,
because it is quite lengthy.
But Istio Control
gives you a lot
of visibility into the different
levels and the different states
a configuration between, again,
the control plane and the data
plane.
So we can switch back to
the slides for a second.
So that was the traffic version.
So for the next demo,
what I want to do
is take a quick walk through
on debugging telemetry.
And so again, just a quick
recap on the way Mixer works.
Those envoy proxy,
that Istio proxy
that sits there inside of your
pod right next your container
is sending telemetry
and metrics information
to Mixer, which is a
control plane component.
Mixer then forwards
that information
onto the backend of your choice.
In this case it could be
Prometheus, Stackdriver,
Datadog, you name it.
The problem is that
the Mixer configuration
is hilariously complicated.
There's a lot of stuff.
So again, our issue
here is that we've
got custom metrics that aren't
showing up in Prometheus.
How do we figure out
what that problem is,
or how do we fix that problem?
So let me just jump over here
back to the demo, please.
And I'm going to switch
to my other cluster.
And this has got a similar
deployment setup already.
The only difference is I
have a little load generator
script that's running just
to generate some load.
So the first thing I want
to do is take a quick look
at Prometheus running
inside this cluster.
So here's the Prometheus entry.
And I have these metrics in
there that just automatically
dump out the temperature of the
cities and when it finds them.
So I can actually start to
look through here and look,
and I'm not seeing
in my metrics.
So we know that's
a problem there.
But the quick thing we can do
is check the service discovery
component and see, can
we find our pods in here.
And if you look, we've got 0
to 99 active targets up there.
That means Prometheus
is not picking up
any metrics from our pods.
It's getting the metrics
out of the Istio proxy,
but nothing in particular from
my applications or my services.
So we that something's
missing on our end,
because if we actually open
this up and dig around--
I'm just going to show
this relatively quickly.
I think that's probably
somewhat challenging to read.
I'll make it a little bigger.
So here's the weather backend.
Here's the weather
backend rule, and we can
see that it's getting dropped.
It's not picking anything
up because I'm not
publishing anything.
And that's the
solution in this case.
I'm actually not
telling Prometheus
how to scrape the metrics out
of my out of my container,
out of my service
container itself.
So the easiest way to do that
is to add some annotations.
And I've actually got a
canned version of this
here that I can show
you very quickly.
And so here's the
bit I need add.
Right down there.
Inside each of my
deployments I need
to make sure I specify a
particular set of annotations
so that Prometheus will
scrape the metrics,
and then include them with
the rest of the Istio metrics
that it's automatically
pulling in by default.
So I can quickly apply
this new configuration,
and then what will happen,
at a matter of a few seconds
or minutes or so, is
that it will start
to see those metrics come in.
We can actually take one
more quick look at Prometheus
and see if that's
working, though.
So I'm going to
refresh this page.
And what you'll see is, inside
of this target, Istio Secure,
it's actually got two new
services that it's picking up,
which are the two
I just annotated.
And if we go back
to the graph, we
can actually start looking
for city temperatures.
That's the a custom
metric I'm outputting.
We can execute a graph there.
So it's only got
one so far, but it's
starting to pick it up now.
The other components of
Mixer, though, there's
a lot of other individual
kind of configuration
there that you might
need to look at.
So one of the ways you can do
that is using kubectl commands.
And if you actually pull
all of the API resources
and grep with just
istio.io, you can
see there's quite a bit of
custom resource definitions
that Istio supplies.
So digging through
this by default,
or just as a kind
of a debugging step,
is a little bit challenging.
So there's a great set of
docs on the Istio IO page
that I want to mention.
Inside the help FAQ,
there's a great page
called missing metrics.
And what it does is
it literally walks you
through every possible sort
of debug step of Mixer.
Now, the challenge is that a
lot of these Mixer components
are very tightly coupled.
So if there is a broken
configuration somewhere where
maybe a rule is not there,
or maybe some of the metrics
aren't there, or maybe it's not
sending information correctly,
one of the easiest steps to
kind of get things back up
and running is to just reapply
that Mixer configuration
and fill in any gaps
that may have occurred.
So if we could switch
back to the slides,
I'm going to show a
quick example of what
that looks like.
So what you end up doing
for Mixer debugging
is confirming the report calls.
And that's where you connect to
one of the Istio telemetry pods
and take a look at its UI.
You can actually curl
against the current metrics
it's sending out to
Prometheus, and it actually
has a bunch of
diagnostics in there.
So you can check those calls.
And you could also look at
just individual configuration
problems, or handlers,
or logs themselves.
For the handlers it just depends
on what your outbound Mixer
config looks like.
If you configured
it for Stackdriver,
you want to see Stackdriver
handlers and adapters.
If you have Prometheus
and Grafana,
you want to see
Prometheus rules in there.
If you're looking at
some of the metrics,
you want to make sure that the
metrics for request count, TCP
request size, bytes, et
cetera, those are in there.
But again, if
something is missing,
it's very hard to pick out
one component and reapply it.
So one of the things
I often end up doing
is pulling down the
latest release of Istio.
In this case, I
used the helm chart.
I generate the helm chart
for the full install
with Mixer on and Mixer off,
I take the diff of those two,
and then I take that little
bit that's left over-- well,
not little.
It's still relatively long--
and then I push that config
back up to their cluster.
So I'm basically
filling in anything
that might have been missing.
Any missing metrics
definitions, any missing rules,
that kind of configuration
kick will solve that problem.
It's not a great
solution at the moment,
but for kind of a
weird set of issues,
that might be your best bet.
Now I think if there are
individual like metric handler
things missing you
might be able to,
again, extract the little
parts of the configuration.
But because there's so many CRDs
and it's very tightly coupled,
it's hard to pick and choose.
Sometimes it's easier just
to reapply and make sure it's
filling in whatever is missing.
With that, I'm going to
hand it off back to Megan
to talk about security.
MEGAN O'KEEFE: Thanks.
Awesome.
I know it's kind of a
whole bunch of demos
and I'm here to do one last
one all about authentication.
So I kind of had to choose
one security demo to do.
So Istio supports
both authentication
and authorization.
So Istio supports end user
authentication with JWT tokens,
as well as service to service
authentication mTLS, as well
as Kubernetes RBAC.
So I had to kind of
choose one, and I
chose mTLS authentication.
How does it work?
I'm going to give a
quick recap before I
dive into the demo about
what we should expect
to be seeing when
we turn on mTLS,
mutual TLS, authentication,
for one service.
The first thing that
happens in the data plane
is a TLS handshake.
So an exchanging of
certain keys from service A
to service B. Then service A
does a secure naming check,
and what this means is
that Istio has a mechanism
to ensure that a client
side service can make sure
that the service side service
is authorized to be running it.
And what this actually means
is a comparison of the service
account against the actual pod
that's running, making sure
it's the real service
B. And finally, there
is a TLS connection
that is established.
What is the actual
Istio architecture
that makes this happen?
So there's two control
plane components
involved in Istio mTLS.
The first is Citadel.
Citadel is responsible
for generating
the certain keys for each of
the sidecar enabled services.
And what Citadel will do
is generate a cert key pair
for the service
account in Kubernetes.
So in my case today, it's just
the default service account.
And then when you enable
sidecar injection,
as I have today for my entire
default namespace on my GKE
cluster, when a new
pod is spawned in GKE,
Kubernetes will mount that cert
key pair, that Citadel created,
as a secret.
Sorry, it's a secret
in Kubernetes,
and Kubernetes mounts
it into the pod.
So whether or not
you've enabled mTLS,
the cert key pair is there.
What this means is
that when you the user
decide that you want to enforce
strict mTLS for a service,
a namespace, or the
entire mesh, you can do so
and it happens very quickly.
So what you would do as the
user is create a policy,
an Istio policy API object, add
it to the Kubernetes API server
through kubectl,
and Pilot, in turn,
is watching the
Kubernetes API server
and creates an envoy filter
and pushes that down.
So it's a multi-step
process, and we're here
today to talk about when
this thing does not go right.
So in this demo, I will be using
the same sample app, weather
info, and I want to enforce mTLS
for only the weather backend.
So this is the yaml that you
would apply to make this work.
It's an Istio policy object, and
you can see there at the bottom
it says peers:mtls.
And I know the syntax
is a bit weird.
It was designed to grow in case
we support more things later.
So it's just mtls, open bracket.
So in this demo, I will be
showing the following things.
So for simplicity
purposes, I only
have one version of the backend
that I'm sending traffic to,
the multiple version.
And what I want
to see is turning
on mTLS for the backend,
and seeing a nice 200 happen
between frontend and backend.
But what I'm seeing
instead is a 503.
So let's walk through that demo.
So if we can switch
to my terminal please.
I know we've had some
glitchy issues that
are sort of Black Mirror
esque on the screen here,
and I apologize for that.
So here I am in my terminal.
I'm not as brave.
I'm not going to be typing
out every single command,
so bear with me as
I go into VS code
and copy paste
some commands here.
Like in the previous demos, I'm
in a cluster with the weather
info app deployed.
I already have Istio
installed on this cluster,
but I do not have any
mTLS policies enabled.
So if I run kubectl
get policies,
I can see there's
nothing there quite yet.
You can see here in 2 out of 2.
What that means is that
there's two containers per pod.
I have turned on Istio Sidecar
Injection for my default
namespace.
So if I try to go to my
weather frontend now,
I can refresh the page.
This is the Istio ingress
gateway external IP,
through which I've
exposed the frontend.
Only multiple showing up.
Just to clarify
exactly why that is,
I literally went in to
Sony's virtual service
and I'm sending all traffic
to the multiple version.
So if we go into the
Istio documentation
on authentication-- if you've
ever been to this page,
it's a bit long but has a
ton of useful information.
What it says here,
if we scroll down
to Authentication
Policies, that if you
want to enable client
side authentication
rules with mutual TLS, you need
both a policy and a destination
rule.
And just straight off the
bat, that can be tricky.
You're like, oh I just
need like a policy,
just like [INAUDIBLE] TLS,
but what this actually means
is that if you have
a destination rule,
you might need to actually
change it to enforce mTLS.
So if I go into the policy
I'm about to enforce,
the reason you
need two resources
is because the policy is what
tells the weather backend
to receive less traffic,
but the destination rule
is what tells the clients of
the weather backend to use TLS.
So mutual means both.
So what we're going to do
is apply these resources
to the cluster and
hope for the best.
And I know yesterday I used
a lot of shell aliases,
so I'm not going
to do that today.
MTLS backend one is the file
that I'm about to apply.
And you can see here that
we created that policy
and that destination
role for weather backend.
So what I hope to see here,
if I keep refreshing the page,
is that what we might start
to see are some 503 errors.
And it can take us
a couple of seconds
to start to propagate down,
but what we will eventually
see within 5 or 10 seconds
is that all connections
between our weather frontend and
the weather backend are 503ing.
And if you use Istio,
raise your hand
if you've seen this
upstream connect error.
Yes.
This is the sort of classic
envoy, ah something's wrong,
error.
And this is what the
backend is reporting,
and we're displaying
it on the front end.
How do we figure out
what's going wrong?
So I have a couple of
things I like to do.
It's somewhat
personal in the way
you want to kind of look at logs
and try to parse everything.
What I like to do in
this case, where I only
have kind of two
services going on,
is to just look at the logs.
So here on the left, I'm showing
the weather frontend logs.
Here on the right, I'm showing
the weather backend logs.
The actual tool I'm using
here is called Stern.
It's a open source
Kubernetes logging
tool that's super
helpful in that you
can use regular expressions to
exclude certain types of logs,
and you can also select
based on deployment.
So you don't actually
need the pod name, which
can be annoying to copy paste.
So what I can see
here is a whole bunch
of output on the
weather backend side.
But if I do a bunch of
like page refreshes, what
I want to be seeing
is a report that we
did a successful request,
and I'm not seeing that.
So it's just a whole bunch of
other cleanup and Mixer logs.
So that's not super helpful.
I'll keep that open in
case I need it later.
So what I want to see
next, if we think back
at that kind of architecture
for mTLS and how to enable it,
there are two Istio
control plane components
we need to check in on.
The first is Pilot,
the second is Mixer.
With pilot, what we
want to make sure
is that Pilot is taking
our configuration
and pushing it down
to the data plane.
So what I will do
here, and sorry
again for this kind
of spammy logs,
is that there are
policies that Pilot
is picking up and sending down.
And you'll notice
here in this log,
Pilot conflict outbound
listener TCP 443,
which is the TLS port, proxy
weather backend single.
OK, but right now we kind
of only care about weather
backend multiple.
And this can be kind of tough
to sort of grep, but we can see,
OK, here's multiple.
This might seem OK.
I worry about Pilot
conflict outbound listener.
That seems bad.
But I'm not totally
sure like what it means.
So at this point I can
either sort of panic,
or kind of think about
the other components.
So there's Citadel too.
It it's like, OK,
maybe there's something
going wrong with Citadel.
Maybe the certain keys are not.
There maybe it's like
a really quick fix.
So what I will next do is make
sure that Citadel is healthy.
Citadel is running.
That's good.
But does that mean that the
keys and certs are there?
So what I will typically
do is this long command--
and I'm copying and pasting
it because it is a bit long--
but what this is doing
is it's [? execing ?]
into each of our front
and back end pods
respectively and checking the
validity of those certain keys.
So I'm going to do that.
So the frontend, we can see
that we have a valid cert,
that the valid times are valid.
And we can do the
same for the backend.
All right, so my hypothesis
that maybe something
was weird with the certs and
keys is kind of not true.
That part seems to be OK.
So now what?
You might be wondering,
what else would envoy
be able to report back to
us that would be helpful.
And what I'm about to
do might sound crazy,
but I'm actually going
to increase the log level
and on void to debug
from default info
to see if we can say anything
more about why requests
to the back end are failing.
So in order to do that--
so when you have
an envoy container,
it actually exposes
an admin console.
It's actually a UI.
I'm not going to show
it today, but there's
some helpful stuff in there.
And you can send requests
to that admin console
to do things with that very
specific envoy by proxy.
So what I'm going
to show here is
calling that admin console
to enable trace level
logs for only the backend.
So you can see here, across
all of envoys loggers,
I've just upped the
log level to trace.
And so what we hopefully
will start to see here
is, if I refresh this
page a whole bunch more,
which is interesting,
there's a whole bunch of logs
that are coming in.
You can see it's now like
debug level, and it's like, OK
how do I even parse this?
And there are a lot
of ways to do it.
Just for purposes
of this demo, I'm
going to do a grep because
I ran this demo before
and I know what I'm looking for.
And to do a grep on
the word handshake.
So if something went wrong
with the exchanging of certs
and keys during that
initial DLS handshake error,
we might be seeing a
TLS handshake error.
So you'll notice that in
the last couple of seconds,
we got a whole
bunch of these debug
logs from envoy that are saying
external envoy SSL handshake
error one.
So what this would tell
me, if I enable mTLS,
is that the very first step of
that TLS connection happening,
that very first step failed.
And I know I have
valid certs and keys
from the envoy proxies,
so I that can't be it.
So typically at this point
I start to blame myself.
What did I do wrong
on the config side
to make this
horribleness happen?
So what I will do is go into all
of the resources that I added
and try to rack my brain.
Oh gosh, what went wrong?
So remember, at
the very beginning,
to make all of this break,
we added a policy one
and a destination rule too.
What is responsible for
each of these components--
so policies for the server side,
destination rule for the client
side--
I will now use
the Istio CTL tool
to try to figure out if
there is a conflict going on
in my configuration.
So Sandeep showed the Istio CTL
command for traffic routing.
I'm going to show
the same command line
tool but just a
different command, which
is authentication TLS check.
And what this does is
compares the destination rule
and the policy for one service
to see if there is a conflict.
And let me get this
a little bit better.
So what we see here
for whether backend--
so I called this command for
just the weather back end--
what we see here is status
conflict, server mTLS,
client HTTP.
That's not what mTLS is, right?
What we hope to see is
server mTLS, client mTLS.
So what's happening here?
What this tells me is that if
we go back to these resources,
destination rule is what tells
clients of the weather backend
to use TLS.
This is the problem.
This is where I
am at this point.
I'm like, OK, there's something
up with my destination rule.
What do I do?
So at this point, what
I will do is run kubectl
get destination rule and see, oh
gosh no, I have two destination
rules for the same service.
This is not good in Istio.
You do not want overlapping
destination rules
that say different things.
So what I'll do at
this point is see
what's actually going on there.
So I'm getting those
two destination rules
and I'm just going to show
the whole yaml output.
So we see both of the
destination rules here.
This is the one I added.
So DR whether backend is the one
I added just a few moments ago.
And this one is good.
Enforce Istio mutual.
This is what I expect to see.
I scroll down, I see
the second destination
rule that was added by
somebody, probably me an hour
ago, that said,
actually, traffic policy
TLS mode disable.
So at this point, envoy
is very confused in
that it thinks it needs
to be doing TLS and not
TLS at the same time.
503.
That's kind of an
oversimplification of what's
actually happening
under the hood,
but what we would
do to fix this is
we would delete the destination
rule that we added before,
and we would modify
the destination rule
we already had.
Surprise, it was in here.
This one that said
TLS mode disable.
We would modify that
to enable mTLS on it.
So I have a file that
does exactly that.
It's here.
I'm going to apply
it to my cluster.
And what we hope to
see, crossing fingers,
is that we can get
back to the backend.
So this doesn't show every
single piece of the debugging
mTLS, but I hope
it kind of sheds
some light about
how not to enter
a complete and
total state of panic
when things go
wrong on that end.
So if we can go back
to the slides, please.
Thank you.
That was just the backup video.
All right, so let's
wrap up a little bit.
What did we learn in this talk?
We only had a certain
amount of time,
so we did kind of have to
pick and choose the demos
that we did.
But things that we
looked at is like, how
to determine if a virtual
service is actually working.
How to use Istio
CTL and the envoy
logs and other tools to really
dig into what's happening.
Sandeep showed us
how to diagnose
missing metrics in Prometheus.
And finally, I just showed
transport level authentication.
Here is a short and
honestly abridged
list of some of the stuff
we used in this talk.
This is not every
single tool that you
can use to diagnose Istio.
We know that the tools
ecosystem is lacking,
and we are talking about
it, and it is something
that we are extremely aware of.
In a perfect world,
I never use curl
to diagnose when
Istio is going wrong.
We need something a
little bit more scalable.
If the promise of
Istio is automation
and being able to
manage hundreds
or thousands of
microservices, we
need something better than curl.
So I'm super excited for
the coming months and years,
and the growing
ecosystem that is Istio.
This is not the end.
If you are still here
for the rest of the day,
there are multiple other
Istio talks, including VM mesh
expansion, CICD
stuff with Istio,
as well as a discussion
of Traffic Director
if that's of interest to you.
A quick call out that we
are conducting user studies
in the coming months for Istio.
If you would like to
join these user studies,
you can grab that QR
code or go to that link.
Our UX team would
love your feedback
and your participation.
Thank you so much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]